your highness your excellencies ladies
and gentlemen as-salaam-alaikum good
evening and on behalf of everyone in the
united kingdom my warmest
congratulations to Andrea's ephyra COO
on winning the global teacher prize 2018
to be chosen from more than 30,000
nominees in 173 countries is an
incredible achievement and it's a
fitting tribute to everything you've
done for your pupils at Albertan
Community School whether it's learning
how to greet pupils in each of their 35
first languages or organizing
extracurricular activities around their
lives rather than the school day you
have shown enormous dedication and
creativity in your work being a great
teacher requires resilience ingenuity
and a generous heart these are the
qualities that you share with your
students every day so thank you for all
you have done and continue to do I would
also like to extend a huge thank you to
His Highness Sheikh Mohammed bin Rashid
Al Maktoum for his support of the
teaching profession and patronage of
this prize and congratulations to the
Varkey foundation for giving us such a
powerful celebration of the work of
teachers and your commitment to
education throughout the world finally
I'd like to say thank you to the other
finalists in this competition and to all
teachers everywhere your profession is
so important sparking curious young
minds and educating the leaders
scientists artists and entrepreneurs of
tomorrow that's why as well as saluting
Andreus achievements the global teacher
prize is a tribute to all teachers so to
our winner her fellow finalists and
every dedicated teacher around the world
thank you and enjoy the rest of the
evening